japan vidéo qui parle de noël sur
youtube j'sais pas moi aussi faire une
vidéo qui parle de noël un minimum
d'originalité sais pas je comptais petit
noël c'est juste magique la lumière dans
la ville l'odeur du sapin le goût du
pain d épices et un chèque de ta grand
mère y est mamie donateurs dans noël
c'est cool j'adore cette fête chaque
année à la laddh étroite que ça arrive a
par contre j'avoue tous les ans c'est un
peu une éternelle répétition il y aura
la rediffusion pour la 600e fois du père
noël est une ordure il y aura ce mec de
ta famille que tu vois jamais de l'année
sauf à noël sorti de chez moi
jetons non plus aoc ouais ça tend to
heaven merci il y aura ces fameux père
noël de décoration qui grimpe les murs
là franchement on dirait soit un mec
tout en brillant chez toi ou un pan du
vin c'est vraiment glauque ils vont
essayer de nous vendre ses pulls de noël
qui sont à la mode pendant deux semaines
à partir du 26 décembre qu'ils sont
totalement périmés comme d'hab y aura
ces gens qui gardent en sapin de noël
trop longtemps même quand la pub épines
on dirait que sapin il a fait une chimio
quand on sortira dehors il y aura cette
ambiance de noël inexplicable dans les
films 1 parce que moi dans mon quartier
c'est plutôt ça et vu qu'il ya une
espèce de sapins et qui s'appelle norman
mois comme chaque année j'aurai le droit
à des blagues à l'infini je fais quoi là
je te mets une guirlande parce que comme
un sapin normal yes bon vin compris et
comme d'hab y aura jean noël qui
ramènera sa science tic à la base le
père noël avant l'été vers et maintenant
il est rouge à cause de coca et c'est
aussi maintenant la petite souris grise
la sacoche de night of your mind your je
suis bourré
quand arrive la période de noël il ya
toujours un mec dans son entourage le
qui plaisantent pas avec ça pour le
minot elle s'est vraiment très sérieux
journée lundi je mangeais de mardi on
n'est pas un jour près jamais
tu les mange dans l'ordre on recommence
bon 23h03 qu'on pouvait les cadres n'ont
jamais on ouvre les cadeaux à minuit ok
oui assez de décoration molle comme ça
je mange au carton si jamais tu
accroches toutes les bottes à la
cheminée on n'a pas chouiner abat un
radiateur
on n'a pas d'horaires non plus au
congrès d'un panda pas grébent à un
briquet alors à temps mais c'est quoi sa
motivation à ce mec je comprends voilà
ok patron a le calvez de l'avant c'est
réglé au niveau de la déco on est bon on
sera prêt pour le 24 fabien michel
continue comme ça et tu finiras chef du
teg ériger une voie de mer et alors je
suis le père noël j'ai ta merde quand tu
es petit tu es cadeaux ils sont un peu
magique
ils sentent noël sans qu'ils ont été
conçus par des petits lutins en pôle
nord dans lucide du père noël
alors que quand tu es grand c'est plus
pareil bon une tringle à rideaux ces
modèles de chez ikea ça c'est lui qui à
-10% à côté du rayon en poule comment te
savais que je voulais ça parce qu'on l'a
achetée ensemble à bord moi je ne
comprends pas les gens qui tenir leurs
cadeaux alors que tu es en train de
l'ouvrir un il gâche complètement le
plaisir bon voilà c'est trop fort hier
j'avais pas d'idées tout était fermé
voilà un titre et un petit peu tard mais
tu peux aller changer c'était pour ta
gueule c'est l'intention qui compte
ok bon ben je vais l'échangé ah oui les
gens qui achètent des cadeaux à leurs
animaux de compagnie c'est super mignon
par contre juste un truc le chemin pour
lui c'est pas noël on sait juste à mardi
ou alors c'est juste
jour numéro 4 112 et un compte à rebours
jusqu'au moment où il arrivera à
l'enlever faut surtout pas oublier qu
avoir des cadeaux à noël c'est vraiment
une chance c'est même un luxe
les parents moi quand j'étais petit à
noël il avait juste une orange
d'ailleurs j'ai jamais compris pourquoi
une orange
pourquoi ce fruit en particulier ouais
mon père est médecin
c'est vrai que maintenant les jouets
pour enfants ils font totalement rêver
j'ai vu magasin de jouets ils vendent
des drones moi quand j'étais petit
j'avais un avion de chasse qui faisait
tout bruit lumière le pilote qui parle
démarrage au sol a maintenant des
réacteurs intérieur ok tour de contrôle
et à ma femme que je reviens ce soir
qu'elle met la bouteille au frais quant
à toi midi et ce soir je devais d'abord
les allées accrochez-vous pas décollé
sauf volé il voulait pas c'était un
avion de chasse avec la fonction d'une
voiture ah merde y'a pas l'option vol ça
fait que rouler en fait bon allez viens
on prend autoroutes en direction le
carrefour market de porte de bagnolet
let's go
[Musique]
alors selon certains parents faux de
dire toute la vérité sur le père noël
aux enfants
c'est un point de vue je respecte ok
mais est ce que dans ce cas là on dit
vraiment tout aux enfants
absolument tout tu vois timothée se
jouer il a été construit par un enfant
taïwanais orphelins qui était payée 3
centimes par jour élu à noël a pas de
cadeaux à p'art l'ouragan coimères avril
c'est pas compliqué de dire la vérité
aux enfants à ne pas répondre pour des
cons un match haut en tout cas le plus
important à noël et ça vous le savez
c'est être entouré des gens qu'on aime
la famille les proches alors pensé ce
soir là plus que jamais a invité les
gens qui sont seules à votre table parce
que passer noël tout seul c'est vraiment
la déprime moi je vous souhaite plein de
bonnes choses
merci pour cette année qui a été pour
moi je crois la plus folle 10 millions
d'abonnés
voilà c'est ça mon cadeau je ne peux pas
rêver mieux donc merci du fond du coeur
profiter au maximum de vos fêtes de fin
d'année et puis surtout joyeux noël
quelqu'un allait jamais à minuit c'est
la messe de minuit
bien joué et michel vous êtes sur un
téléphone alors appuyé de votre doigt
sans ma grosse tête ici pour vous
abonner facilement et en fait ça marche
aussi de qu'un ordi alors elle est pas
belle la vie
[Musique]